[Music]
and the Democratic mayor of Eagle Pass
Texas says migrants are overrunning his
City this is Texas governor Greg Abbott
holds the line at Shelby Park where the
where the Biden Administration wants to
cut through razor wire placed by state
authorities that's a controversy that's
ongoing Matt Finn is there in Eagle Pass
with more from the mayor hi
Matt hi Dana this morning the state of
Texas is Banning Biden's border Agents
from Shelby Park where I'm standing and
this showdown is happening in the of
Eagle Pass I caught up with the
Democratic mayor and a democratic
Council woman who say their own town has
been overrun by illegal immigration for
years and they both have joined a chorus
of leaders down in this region who say
they feel abandoned by the Biden
Administration and are urging both sides
to work together to find a
solution because yes we need to stop it
from happening the way it's happening
it's not uh it's not humanly right but
at the same time they're under uh right
to defend and and and stop it somehow
because I mean come on 68 million people
crossing in the last three year I mean
three years it's just getting out of
hand we're having our checkpoints uh
closed I don't know I mean for God's
sake I don't know how many people
already pass I don't want people here
coming illegally I'm all for legal
migration uh I don't support people
coming in and crossing the river and
staying here in the United States I
think those people should be sent back
immediately because it's not fair for
the people that do it the right
way now Texas's fortification of this
illegal Crossing hotspot appears to be
working for now we have noticed with our
own eyes a major plummet in large groups
here and now the mayor and the Texas
National Guard tell me the number of
Crossings has dropped from that high of
up to 4,000 last month a day down to
about a few hundred a day this month now
typically colder months that we are in
we do see a Slowdown so the coming
months as it warms up we'll likely
reveal whether Texas's razor wire
barrier is keeping the large groups away
but then of course it becomes the
question of wack-a-mole if the migrants
are not crossing here are they going to
be heading to places like New Mexico and
California Dana all right Matt Finn
thank you I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme
and I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis